a very good morning to you the
government will announce changes to the
traffic light list of travel
destinations today with holiday makers
waiting to learn whether new countries
will be given the green light for summer
trips
but while travel industry leaders have
been imploring to get more planes in the
sky
one industry expert has warned sky news
the testing system for foreign travel
is not equipped to cope with an influx
of demand
it comes as concerns over kovid 19
variants show
no signs of abating with the prime
minister warning he won't hesitate to
cull the green list
if necessary iva bennett reports
hello alberts travel at abbott's travel
in redbridge they're busier than ever
but they're still not making any money
you'll have to do a pcr within three
days of your return from
from portugal that's because instead of
taking new bookings
owner julian's mostly changing or
cancelling old ones
day to day it's a nightmare you know
with what with the red the orange the
green
um if i'd had my way i think it would
have been red throughout until there's
more clarity the uncertainty over which
destinations will go where
in the revised travel traffic light list
means customers
and agents are hedging their bets so
that people can secure a holiday in say
july or august
we're actually booking three or four
different destinations
under our atoll and holding them for as
long as possible without actually having
to take money from the client
so that you know they're not financially
committed
but even with multiple bookings a
holiday is not guaranteed
it's thought malta and some greek
islands could be added to the green list
but the prime ministers warned countries
could equally move the other way
anxious times then for anyone hoping to
travel
i've been on turn to hook sort of the
last
couple of weeks really just waiting
justine's hoping cyprus turns green
in time for her wedding there next month
we already put it on on hold for one
year
we just really want to get married now
and and get out there if we possibly can
um we'll face you know the tests and
isolation if we have to when we get back
portugal is the only major tourist
destination currently on the green list
after restrictions lifted last month
travellers don't have to self-isolate on
return
but they must all take a covid test
industry experts fear that if the green
list does expand
the testing system will be overwhelmed
the providers
to us were saying the test providers
it's simply not set up to deal with the
numbers of people who need to use it
so if we see the canary island spain
greece some big destination that
hundreds of thousands of people want to
go to turn up on the green list
it's very hard to see how that system is
going to cope
demand is certainly there but will there
be destinations to match
depending on where you want to go a
foreign holiday
may still be very far away iva bennett
sky news well the prime minister and the
chancellor are being criticized
for withholding money to deal with the
post-pandemic schools recovery in
england boris johnson's school's
catch-up czar
quit last night saying the funding
allocated was
only half-hearted well let's get to our
political correspondent
jamara cohen and how just how big a blow
is this going to be for the government
as it tries to to move forward and show
that it does care about schools
it's very damaging to his credibility
stephen the prime minister hired sir
kevin collins to advise him
on how to help children recover from the
pandemic the prime minister's talked a
lot about this being part of his
leveling up agenda
to help children wherever they live to
get a great education
and that education commissioner has
essentially resigned
saying the plan was too small too narrow
and they needed to have much bigger
thinking
and the prime minister rejected that so
that does really leave a big question as
to
where this now is catch-up plan now goes
it also exposes quite an interesting
dynamic with a chance to the rishi sunac
because
i understand that it was the treasury
that cut down that plan from 15 billion
to just one and a half they thought it
wasn't fully worked through they wanted
to look at it again they've obviously
got huge demands
on on a small pot of money and boris
johnson went along with their thinking
on that so
it seems that rishi sunak wants to keep
tighter control of the purse strings and
that's going to be very interesting over
the next few months
meanwhile there's more trouble brewing
for the government isn't there in terms
of the foreign aid potentially yes on
monday
you'll remember a few months ago the
government cut back on its commitment to
spend 0.7 percent
of national income on aid back to 0.5
we've been hearing on sky news this week
about some of the effects of that
on fragile countries like south sudan
now some quite influential conservatives
including jeremy hunt
andrew mitchell david davis are clubbing
together to try and amend some quite
obscure
legislation on monday but the effect of
it will essentially be
to force the government to have 0.7 back
now they'll need about 45 conservative
mps to go with them on this
if they get that it will be a very big
rebellion for the government
okay tomorrow for now thank you
we'll sort of come on the program for
you this morning as the government
prepares to announce which countries are
going to be added onto the green list
we'll talk to the shallow treasury
minister
james murray to get labour's perspective
that's at half past seven
at 20 past eight we'll talk to the
alcohol awareness charity drinkaware
about the rise in damaging drinking
habits during the pandemic
at a half past eight we'll meet the
ten-year-old boy who suffered
major burns at a family barbecue as he
sets out to raise money for the hospital
that treated him
israel is on the brink of a new
political era after a coalition of
parties reached a deal to form a
government moving a step
closer to ousting binyamin netanyahu an
agreement has been reached between a
group of
right center and center left parties
it follows four inconclusive elections
in just two years
mark stone reports
he's been written off so many times and
despite a momentous day for israeli
politics
and an opposition which says it now can
form a government
the man they call the magician may still
hang on
after four inconclusive elections in
just two years opposition
leader yaya lapid says he's managed an
unwieldy left
center right coalition a majority to
kick netanyahu out
but to secure that majority the
journalist and tv presenter turned
centrist politician
has had to promise the top job to
someone else
naftali bennett to netanyahu's right on
the political spectrum
is set to be israel's new prime minister
a turbulent 24 hours saw a new president
voted in two
but will this be the day remembered as
the moment that ever-present figure in
israeli
and global politics for three decades
was pushed out
his allies are certainly not writing him
off yet
well i i i will be cautious and i will
not start to
sum up his political career we have seen
in the past that he
he pulled out magics out of his sleeves
when people started to
sum up his career and that magic will
involve what one person close to the
negotiations told me
will be days of hell netanyahu will chip
away at the coalition
trying to peel off individual
politicians to remove the majority
before the vote of confidence which will
probably be next week
since he was first elected in 1996 he
has been the consummate political
operator the survivor
the self-caste defender of the nation
where should a red line be drawn against
the iranians
the palestinians and the coronavirus
he's a whole football team from the
goalkeeper to the striker
on the pitch constantly fighting for
political
survival and anshul pfeffer is
netanyahu's unofficial biographer
i don't think this is the end of
netanyahu uh
even if this new government of
jail lapid and nathalie bennett and all
these other parties
from every part of the israeli political
spectrum
manages to somehow survive for the next
four years
and zenyatta will still be around he'll
still be the leader of liquids
if the netanyahu maneuvers fail and the
coalition holds it's unlikely any of its
individual party's more radical plans
will emerge
core issues like the israel-palestine
conflict will remain intransigent
but oddly netanyahu has succeeded in
creating an extraordinary unity against
him
on the left a secular centrist in the
middle a hardline nationalist
and on the right an israeli arab all in
a coalition together
mark stone sky news in jerusalem
well let's return return to our main
news this morning obviously he's looking
at the
the announcement on the travel traffic
light system which we're expecting today
and also of course the
fallout from the resignation of sir
kevin collins the
catch-up tsar yesterday we can talk to
the minister
for safeguarding victoria atkins good to
see you
this morning look can we kick off with
with the the education
situation the prime minister has said
time and time again that education
was his priority and yet the man that he
appointed to
to really sort this out and and get
things back on track for millions of
school children resigned
saying the government just isn't doing
enough that's hugely damning isn't it
well look at the i think we all
acknowledge that
young people and children have had an
incredibly tough year with the
coronavirus pandemic
um they've had to make huge sacrifices
not just in education but in all sorts
of other ways as well
which is why the prime minister is
determined to help them get back on
track
and to ensure that we uh catch up and we
level up with uh education across the
country
we're incredibly grateful to sir kevin
for the work that he has
done uh on the programme of work
um but we have announced the investment
of 1.4 billion pounds worth of
additional funding this is a huge amount
of money
and it's very much focused on uh what we
can deliver
and deliver quickly and so we know for
example that one to
sir kevin says this is too narrow too
small and too
slow far from you delivering it quickly
it says you can't do it quickly enough
with this amount of money
well the the 1.4 billion is being
invested
one one billion pounds worth of it is
being invested
in uh 15-hour tutoring courses we know
that
really effective one-to-one coaching can
um boost
about three or five months worth of
uh education so this is what the focus
of this
uh additional funding is and then in
terms of the
wider um work that sir kevin has been
recommending for example lengthening the
school day
this is very much you know we are
working on this there is a review that
will take place
to see how uh that would uh manifest
itself but we
very much want to work with children
with parents and with teachers to ensure
this
package of 1.40 pounds really has the
impact that we all want it to have
well if 1.4 billion pounds is enough
in your view why was the department for
education
pushing for 13 billion well i i don't
know
where those figures have come from and i
hope you'll understand that i haven't
been involved in the discussions with
treasury but um this is a huge amount of
funding i mean it's on top of the 1.7
billion pounds
that we announced last year again the
focus of
of this total of three billion pounds
has been very much on helping the
most disadvantaged children to catch up
we want to help teachers as well there's
part of this week's announcement is
about helping
teachers develop both um teachers i mean
yeah i mean
look forgive me i mean we've heard we've
heard all the rhetoric about how the
money is going to do great and wonderful
things but the problem is
you know your appointed tsar says you
need 15 billion
we know from people we've talked to here
that the department for education wanted
13 billion
and yet you get 1.4 now
something's gone wrong there hasn't it
well again i i can't
i don't know those figures so i i can't
confirm them either way but what i do
know is that this
is as the prime minister made clear
yesterday this is part of our ongoing
work to
help those children who have been most
um disadvantaged by the pandemic so
as i say last year we announced 1.7
billion pounds of funding
and we're trying to really target it to
those children who need it most
this is an additional 1.4 billion pounds
that we've announced
this week and again we're focusing on
this one-to-one
tuition because we know that that can
have a really
positive impact on a child who's been
left behind in the pandemic
and then we are continuing to look at
things like um
lengthening the school day because we
understand you know
kevin colin has looked into that very
carefully but we've got to take
parents and teachers and everyone with
us on this journey we've got to
understand what
the uh impacts the intended and
unintended uh impacts of
that sort of work will be so this is
very much
work but look i mean you you keep saying
the focus on those
most disadvantaged which you know is
laudable
except sir kevin collins says in parts
of the country where schools were closed
for longer
such as the north the impact of low
skills on productivity
is likely to be particularly severe
so i mean he's saying you're not doing
it you're really not doing enough with
this package
for those children who have been most
badly affected
well i i having read his statement i'm
not sure that was quite
the point he was making with that point
if i may say so but i do take it
you know i appreciate the quote but what
i'm saying is i think
you know the point about targeting those
children who are most affected by the
pandemic is
absolutely what this money is about we
want to have a
as i said course of tutoring um 15-hour
tutoring courses for um up to
up to six million um of these courses
that's 100 million
uh tuition hours uh estrogen that this
money is paying for and it's going to be
helping those children
who are most disadvantaged by this we've
got to
spend this money wisely we want to have
it we want it to have the most
impact it can possibly have and that's
why
looking at the evidence that we've seen
thus far we're focusing on this
one-to-one tuition
to really try to boost children's
chances in the years ahead
can i ask you about the the travel
traffic light list i know you're not
going to tell us
what is changing today but there is real
concern
from experts in the industry that we've
spoken to who say
if that green list is actually expanded
then the testing facilities will just
not be able to cope
if you if the list is expanded you're
going to have to remove
the testing requirements on return
aren't you
no our policy is quite long
long standing now in terms of
international travel and the testing
regime
for people returning from overseas
is very much it's very clear you know
red amber green
um so that testing regime will stay and
this is why you know
the testing regime is one part of
the overall picture that the joint
center
has to look at but also of course the
secretary of state has to look at so
there are also but the experts are
saying the experts are saying the
logistics
simply cannot cope with increased
testing they're just not going to be
able to do it well again
these are factors that will be taken
into account alongside
lots of other factors when the secretary
of state makes the announcement later
today
and can i ask you about foreign aid i
mean obviously andrew mitchell and
others are
wanting to bring an amendment next week
which will force
the government to return to 0.7
uh contribution to foreign aid
this was a manifesto commitment in in
2019.
do you think it should be restored
well the prime minister has made clear
that this is a temporary measure i mean
in 2019 no one could have foreseen
the extent of the pandemic and the
measures we were going to have to take
as a country in order to deal with this
it has had a huge impact on our economy
we've managed to protect more than
14 million jobs we've managed to keep
small and medium businesses
keep going with small business grants
and so on i've seen that in my own
constituency
but this has had a huge cost to our
economy
we've invested something like 400
billion pounds worth to keep the economy
uh going
and so we've had to make some very very
difficult decisions but the prime
minister has been clear
that this is a temporary measure that we
will be very much
returning to it when the fiscal
situation permits us to do so
and i would just say that even with this
a small temporary
election we also are the largest
uh donors of aid in the world
spending more than 10 billion pounds
made
and so i do believe we still have a
record of which we
can you know very much hold our head up
high in terms of international
development
it's what we do to take these very
difficult decisions
given the circumstances that have arisen
with the pandemic
the singaporean authorities have started
an investigation after a cargo ship
registered to the country caught fire
and began to sink off the coast of sri
lanka
triggering fears of an environmental
disaster
the ship was carrying nearly 1500
containers
including 25 tons of nitric acid
and other chemicals well let's uh get
the latest from our southeast asia
correspondent siobhan robbins who's
following the story
from bangkok what more do we know
siobhan
morning stephen well just to bring
people up to date this all began
on the 20th of may when there was an
explosion on board the ship which was
moored off the coast of sri lanka the
explosion started a fire and from that
it's
triggered a range of potential
environmental threats so if we go
through them first of all of course
there's the fire the smoke
pumping into the atmosphere but also the
fire
meant that some of the containers that
were on the ship
toppled into the sea polluting the water
around them
one of the other problems is that some
of the containers that were on the ship
contained little plastic pellets which
are used for things like
making plastic bags they've now washed
into the ocean
and one environmentalist has suggested
that up to three
billion of them are now floating around
in the ocean
the problem with that is that they are
not only plastic but they aren't
biodegradable
so they're going to stay in that marine
environment potentially forever
they're also washing onto sri lanka's
pristine
beaches and as well as that we've got
the chemicals that are on board the ship
and also the fact that it's been
estimated by other environmentalists
that they're around 81
hazardous uh containers containers
containing hazardous
uh items including 400 containers of
oil and the concern is uh that as this
ship
continues to be in distress that the oil
will also sink
uh seep out into the sea now the plan
had been to try and
tow the ship out essentially so that
it would dilute the amount of waste
going into the water but because
of the distress that it's been in that
hasn't actually been possible so it's
continuing
uh to pollute the water around it it's
now partially sunk
fisher who are based in sri lanka have
been told they can't fish in that area
and this is a really concerning
environmental situation
facing sri lanka okay siobhan thank you
okay this is sky news breakfast let's
see what's happening in the weather for
you this morning because we've had a
lovely few days across the uk haven't we
the big question is
is it going to continue morning mass
good morning it is going to be mostly
fine for the rest of the week but it
certainly won't be as hot as the last
few days
still warm enough for most places today
but there will also be a bit of wet
weather about
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it was certainly a hot one
yesterday in fact
england wales and scotland all saw their
highest temperature of the year
so far and northern ireland equaled its
highest temperature of the year so far
it won't be as hot today in fact it's
going to generally feel
a lot less or a warmer but it will still
be quite warm across the eastern parts
of england
until then it's a cloudy start this
morning there are showers across parts
of northern ireland south west scotland
into northwest england
and northern ireland will become drier
into and brighter this afternoon as that
showery rain shifts up towards the
western parts of scotland continuing
across parts of northern england
some showers developing over western
parts of ireland but elsewhere brighting
up
feeling very warm around eastern england
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now earlier this hour the home office
minister victoria atkins defended the
government's 1.4 billion pound
funding pledge to help pupils catch up
following prolonged school closures
because of the pandemic and it comes
after the so-called catch-up
tsar sir kevin collins resigned last
night
saying that package falls far short
of what is needed and what he
recommended let's talk to labour's
shadow treasury minister
james murray would you fund a 15 billion
pound plan if you had the option
so we've set out a children's recovery
plan which comes to around a similar
amount
um and we've developed that working with
teachers
with parents and so on to show what
children really need
and i think what the government has has
been exposed as having done is not
prioritizing children's education not
prioritizing the well-being
of children and yeah this is the
chancellor's uh responsibility for not
putting the funding forward and i think
it's really
it's really telling that so kevin
collins you know he has resigned over
this he's been very clear
that he was brought in as an expert he
hasn't been listening to
what the government is proposing does
not go as far
anywhere near as far as what he wanted
and actually our plan that we put
forward
is very similar in terms of magnitude to
what he was proposing and really
you know i think everyone listening to
this show will realize that
what the government is doing by
shortchanging children
feels wrong but it's also the ultimate
false economy
uh you know we don't invest in
protecting our children now in making
sure
that their education catches up uh that
they are prepared in terms of their
mental well-being
and so on uh it's gonna cost the country
and the economy
ideally in the long run yeah but i mean
one of the big
chunks of that 15 billion pounds
if it had been delivered would have been
to pay for
extra time at school an extra half hour
on the school day i mean
the labour party is opposed to that
anyway aren't you
so what we said in our children's
recovery plan which as i said was
developed
very carefully yeah are you opposed to
that or not
well what we were saying is that this
school if the school of days is extended
a bit
that should be not just about uh
teaching not just about doing
you know maths at five or six o'clock in
the evening but also about all those
extra-curricular
activities the breakfast clubs making
sure that people
the children get access to a wider
set of experiences and socializing with
other children
which is something people have missed
out on so much over the last year
yeah forgive me i sounded a bit rude
when i asked that um which i am sorry
about look
in in terms of all this money that you
say you're going to put forward and you
say the government should have
prioritized school children over
um prioritize them over who over
taxpayers who have to fund this
ultimately over
people on furlough who may see that
withdrawn
pretty soon i mean why prioritize school
children over all these other issues
which are very important at the moment
what we said is the money uh to pay for
this children's recovery plan should
come from the kovid reserves
which the government have already
identified now the government
as i say these they've identified this
money as a reserve that should go
into tackling covet and i think we're
particularly now getting to the stage
of the outbreak where we can see uh the
long-term impacts that this this is
having
on children on the next generation and
if we're starting to make choices about
how that covert reserve money should be
spent
i think it is the right decision to say
some of that money should go toward
their children toward making sure that
they are able to catch up not just
educationally but also
in terms of their wider well-being and
social uh growing up and so on so
it's a choice that we have to make
around how the coverage reserve money is
spent
and i think what the chancellor has
shown um is that he's taking the wrong
decision
you know he's taking a decision not to
put that money into supporting children
and as i said
it doesn't just feel wrong it also is a
false economy the ultimate force economy
you know we know that if we don't
invest in children's education and their
well-being and so on an early stage
um it costs children dear it costs the
country and the economy
and deer in the long run so it's the
wrong choice from the chancellor
and as i say it's the ultimate force
economy well okay can i ask you about
the traffic the travel situation the
travel
traffic light system easy for me to say
and what what do you think should
happen today well what we said
uh with the uh the traffic light system
for travel is that the ambulance
should be scrapped because i think what
has really confused the situation and
it's having that ambulance where
people don't know fully how it works
there are countries on the ambulance
uh where there are concerns about
whether people should be coming
from that country into the uk you know
we believe this should be the red list
and the green list
yeah straightforward but but do you do
you want to see that green list extended
i mean michael o'leary yesterday
from ryanair saying really it should be
all of mainland europe
opened up now because you know the way
the vaccination system
is going should that happen well
i mean we all want to be able to get
back to life as normal as possible as
soon as we can but it's got to be driven
by the data you know we've got to look
at what's happening
in other countries and we've got to
proceed and carefully to make sure that
any
gains that we've made in terms of being
able to have
fewer restrictions in this country at
the moment are not undermined
by new variants coming into the country
in cases uh going back up again
so you know what's really important is
that we take this in a
in a careful way looking at the data but
also we clear up this mess which has
been created by having this amber system
by not having clear instructions in
place by not having the resources in
place
at the border force at airports and so
on you know the whole
the whole story of the last year about
the border policy
on quarantining has been one of
incompetence and chaos
and we need to now finally get a grip
james murray good to talk to you this
morning thank you
thank you well let's get more now
on that uh catch-up situation for school
children the catch-ups are
quitting last night saying you know what
he wanted to happen just wasn't and the
government wasn't doing enough so
let's talk to the former children's
commissioner for england and longfield
who joins us now good to see you what do
you make of what's going on
well i think it's a mess and it's
disappointing and
it's a huge loss having said kevin
collins uh resign
not just because of the expertise that
he's brought to this and the huge
respect that he brings with it
and the sector as well but also what it
means and he's been very clear in his
um statements he's made that he doesn't
feel he had any option
he came into this job with a serious job
ahead um
he uh poured his um efforts
into that and came up with a plan which
i think had widespread
credibility seemingly it had the prime
minister's credibility
but it seems to have stalled and i'm for
one
um not sure where it goes from here but
think government needs to
rethink on this one i mean what we've
been told is that this is the beginning
of a process
yeah 1.7 billion allocated earlier on
1.4
yesterday and this is a pro they haven't
ruled out extending the school day they
haven't ruled anything out at this stage
so
can we have some confidence perhaps that
things will evolve
well um i'm not sure i mean all the
words are that
yes this is this is not the end which of
course is
um has an element of reassurance um
but the the funding that's been uh made
available this week of course it's
welcome
funding is welcome schools will be able
to make produce fit children
will benefit but it's not the scale in
any way
of the kind of recovery package that was
being proposed
we have children who've been out of
school for weeks on end
they've really suffered in terms of
their emotional mental health
they really need to be able to get that
confidence back and what was being
proposed was a whole range of measures
around their well-being around pest
pastoral care
around early years very young children
have suffered too
and i think that would have been hugely
hugely not only beneficial for children
i think we can understand that
but really welcome for families too
they know what their children have
suffered and it really won't be good
enough to wait
a year plus for those measures to come
into place
we have had to spend money during the
pandemic and rightly so
and had to spend large amounts of money
on
uh programs such as furlough which i
think we all think
was money very well spent but that was
costing six to seven
billion pounds a month at various stages
now
that puts the kind of money that's been
looked at here into perspective
and children really do need that input
from the pandemic
here and now but there could well be
people watching
who say yes you know that catch-up is
important
children have missed out and money needs
to be spent
but should we be spending this level of
money
on things like pastoral care early
morning breakfast clubs after school
activities shouldn't we focus on the
academic here isn't it i mean
you can understand people's perspective
on that can't you
it's right of course that anyone should
you know scrutinize where public money's
going
uh it's precious and it needs to be
spent well um but
learning at school takes many forms and
children have many roots into that
of course academic achievement is
important getting children back to the
point where
they can reach the grades that that we
all hope they'll be able to progress to
is very important there's priorities
around that but there are many more ways
of engaging children
in their learning and for those that
aren't motivated academically then
access by sports and music and arts and
the like
can really bring benefits in terms of
their grades but
do so in a much broader way and for the
families who are struggling to get back
to get back to work
they too need that help and support so i
think this is about helping children to
learn building relationships with their
teachers which we know
is going to be really important but also
to
really have that breadth of support that
will enable children
not needed to catch up but also to get
ahead and of course those who need it
most
are the children who have been
disadvantaged from before
um the pandemic struck they're already
behind and they're even further behind
at this stage can i ask you about
extending the school day which is one of
the measures we know sir kevin wanted to
bring in
and that hasn't been possible at this
time and we'd only extend it in some
cases from
from 245 to 315 or maybe from three till
to 3 30. some teaching unions are
against that the labour party doesn't
seem overly
sure about that do you think it would be
a good idea
well i do and i've advocated extending
the school day for
a long long time but not purely for
extra lessons and not purely for
teachers to have to teach them
i think what's important here is you are
going to extend the school day that you
have a mix
of the enrichment activities the
additional activities
and also some opportunities to reaffirm
their learning
and also some some
some teaching within that i think the
proposals would have been
very clear that teachers will have
options whether they
um take part in that but there are
always teachers who are
agency teachers or retired teachers that
are keen to
do this sort of thing and also others
that will come in
sports coaches arts coaches and the like
so i think really
it's about being creative at this point
many many schools do this
but they need resources to make it part
and parcel
of their day and that's what this would
have offered now campaigners are calling
on g7 leaders to take action to close
the coronavirus vaccine gap between
their nations and poorer countries
it comes as philanthropist bill gates
has renewed a call for wealthier nations
to accelerate global vaccine access well
let's talk to
oriella guyan who's the managing
director of the office of the kovacs
facility at gabby the
vaccine alliance good to see you this
morning look
what needs to be done with what level of
urgency
there are very welcome news we had our
advanced market commitment summit for
cobax yesterday
we managed to raise 2.4 billion dollars
to buy kobit-19 vaccines
for the developing world so with funding
what we need now is to secure doses and
we need to deliver doses
we urgently need countries who have
excess supply
to donate their doses so we can start
increasing the coverage level
in developing countries and help end the
pandemic in terms of
of of the money raised to buy doses i
mean
is there a problem just accessing the
supply chain at the moment because
demand is so high
indeed we're in a situation of acute
supply shortage
and um so we have been able to secure
two billion doses to roll out across
192 countries
but there are a lot of doses that
are currently held by countries who have
excess supply
and so what we're calling on countries
to do is release that excess supply
share those doses so that we can start
rolling them out as soon as possible
i mean there has been calls from some
nations hasn't there to
if countries released 20 of their excess
supply even which still gives them a bit
of
a bit of flexibility at home would that
make a significant difference
it would make a huge difference um we
estimate that there's maybe up to 1.5
billion doses
that would not be used even if the
countries were to fully cover
their their population that would really
help
us to be able to roll out the doses now
so that we can
stem the pandemic and uh fight against
the the rise of variants that we're
seeing
how problematic are the logistics of all
of this so i mean i know i think
i think i'm writing saying it was malawi
where 20 000 doses had to be destroyed
because they'd just
gone past the their expiration date i
mean logistically
it's quite difficult to get these out to
people isn't it
so rolling out vaccines in a lower
resource settings is a challenge at the
best of times and
of course uh we are far from being at
the best of times
uh right now so what we really need is
to be able to have
uh the the planning horizon to be able
to help prepare countries
prepare their cold chain train their
health care workers
make sure that they're able to to deal
with the the shelf life
of the vaccines we also have to be
mindful that
at the moment because the vaccine
development was very fast
uh the shelf life of the the doses um
is relatively short as the manufacturers
are still gathering data
and so over time as we get more data the
shelf life should
increase that that should help with the
planning of and the rollout
but really right now a lot of attention
needs to go into the delivery of
vaccines indeed
in terms of these poorer nations we know
there is
and it's it's partly a sort of cultural
issue is
is vaccine hesitancy i mean we see it in
all countries but
i mean particularly in some of these
poorer nations how
how do you begin to to address that
because there really needs to be a
level of trust built up doesn't there
indeed confidence in vaccines is very
important
and it has to happen at the level of the
community
and it what we need is to be able to
communicate the benefits of the vaccines
at the level where the community can
have a high level of acceptance and that
involves engaging community leaders
religious leaders it's not just a
top-down government approach
and this is where a lot of communication
needs to to go on
a lot of um work also in terms of
dealing with misinformation of vaccines
which we're seeing
a certain number of uh within the social
media and making sure that the best and
correct information
is available to everyone so that they
can make an informed choice
uh to take the vaccine what one thing
that we don't necessarily get i mean i
think i'm thinking particularly
of african nations we don't seem to be
getting a lot of data on the spread of
coronavirus
in some of those countries at least i
mean what are we seeing on the ground
so surveillance is indeed much more
limited
in developing countries and so we
probably estimate
that the the case numbers and the
fertility rates are probably
under uh reported and so part of the
effort
in terms of delivering the vaccines is
also to increase this surveillance
so that we can make sure that we have a
better understanding
the other thing that we need to do is
make sure that we understand
which variants are circulating and being
able to to track those
so this takes time effort and money
are you confident that world leaders
that the the richer leaders
do pay attention to what you're saying
are really appreciating that without a
a global solution here it's not going to
stop problems within their own borders
what we saw yesterday at the kovacs amc
summit that my organization gavi hosted
is that over 40 countries
um private sector and governments came
together and pledged
2.4 billion dollars to help us secure
more access for covid vaccines so
there is a strong attention being paid
but more needs to be done
we really need to all come together make
sure that
uh the doses that we have today are best
used and that involves
sharing doses so that they can be rolled
out immediately
as soon as um as possible to
uh make sure that we have the coverage
levels rise in developing countries
in the same way that it's being rising
in developed countries